Si tu fais tourner une balle autour d'un axe puis d'un autre, ce n'est pas la même chose que de faire les deux rotations dans l'ordre inverse.
Aujourd'hui dans Qiskit en classe, nous verrons ce que cette balle a à voir avec les ordinateurs quantiques et l'un des plus célèbres
principes de la mécanique quantique : le principe d'incertitude.
Bienvenue dans Qiskit en classe, une série vidéo où nous décortiquons un concept fondamental que tu
pourrais rencontrer dans un cours lié à l'informatique quantique. Chaque vidéo est accompagnée d'un module interactif dont le lien se trouve dans
la description ci-dessous, alors n'hésite pas à y jeter un œil. Aujourd'hui, nous parlons du principe d'incertitude de Heisenberg. Si
tu en as déjà entendu parler, tu connais peut-être aussi la vieille blague sur Heisenberg. Un jour, il s'est fait arrêter au volant et le policier lui a demandé : savez-vous
à quelle vitesse vous rouliez ? Heisenberg a répondu : non, mais je sais exactement où je suis. C'est un peu
le principe d'incertitude de Heisenberg en résumé : tu ne peux pas connaître simultanément la position et la quantité de mouvement d'une particule
avec une précision parfaite. On l'écrit souvent comme ceci : Delta x fois Delta p est supérieur
ou égal à h barre sur 2, où Delta X et Delta P sont les
incertitudes sur la position et la quantité de mouvement, et h barre est une minuscule constante fondamentale en mécanique quantique.
Heisenberg a formulé cette inégalité en 1927, en imaginant comment mesurer la position d'un électron. Si
tu fais rebondir un photon dessus pour voir où il se trouve, ce photon va inévitablement donner un coup à l'électron et perturber sa
quantité de mouvement. Ce n'est pas simplement un énoncé sur les mesures qui perturbent un système : cela nous dit qu'il y a des limites
fondamentales à ce que nous pouvons apprendre sur la nature. C'est un exemple d'un principe plus large appelé la complémentarité, qui
dit que certains aspects de la nature sont incompatibles entre eux et ne peuvent pas être observés
simultanément. Par exemple, les objets quantiques se comportent parfois comme des particules et parfois comme des ondes,
mais tu ne peux pas observer les deux comportements simultanément. La relation de Heisenberg sur la position et la quantité de mouvement ne couvrait qu'un
ensemble parmi de nombreux ensembles de caractéristiques complémentaires. Cette incertitude inhérente est liée à la façon dont nous percevons des propriétés comme
la position et la quantité de mouvement en mécanique quantique. Au lieu de penser à X et P comme des variables ou des propriétés intrinsèques
que chaque particule possède, en mécanique quantique, la position et la quantité de mouvement sont des opérateurs. Ce ne sont pas des propriétés d'un
système mais des choses que tu peux faire à un système. Connaître la position d'une particule nécessite maintenant de réaliser une
opération sur ce système et de faire une mesure. Cette opération pourrait affecter le résultat d'autres opérations
ultérieures. Par analogie, pense à un morceau de bois sec. Il a de nombreuses propriétés comme sa
position, sa taille, sa forme. Il a aussi la propriété d'être combustible et d'être flottable dans l'eau. Si ce bois était un
objet quantique, ce ne seraient pas des propriétés que tu pourrais simplement connaître a priori. Au lieu de cela, nous disons que ce sont des
observables, des choses que tu peux apprendre sur le système si tu réalises une opération dessus. Tu devrais donc appliquer des opérateurs
de « combustibilité » ou de « flottabilité », ce qui nécessiterait d'essayer réellement de brûler le bois ou de le mettre dans
l'eau pour voir s'il flotte. Maintenant, le résultat de chacun de ces opérateurs dépend de l'ordre dans lequel tu les appliques. Si
tu testes d'abord la combustibilité, le bois brûlera en cendres et tu ne pourras pas tester s'il flotte. Mais si tu testes
la flottabilité d'abord, il sera trop mouillé pour brûler. On dit que les opérateurs de combustibilité et de
flottabilité ne commutent pas : l'ordre des opérations compte. Cela mène à une limite
fondamentale sur la précision avec laquelle ces deux observables peuvent être connues pour le morceau de bois, puisque nous ne pouvons pas dire avec certitude s'il est
combustible ou flottable sans connaître le contexte de cette mesure. Bien sûr, avec un vrai morceau de bois, tu
pourrais le couper en deux et tester les deux propriétés simultanément, mais tu ne peux rien faire de tel avec une particule quantique. Cette
analogie avec le bois n'est que cela, une analogie. L'incertitude est quelque chose d'uniquement quantique. X et P ne commutent pas non plus,
et cette propriété de non-commutativité est ce qui mène au principe d'incertitude de Heisenberg. En général, deux opérateurs quelconques
qui ne commutent pas auront leur propre relation d'incertitude. La forme générale du principe d'incertitude peut être
écrite comme ceci : Delta A fois Delta
B est supérieur ou égal à
un demi fois le crochet de A et B, où
ce crochet est appelé le
commutateur, et c'est égal à la différence entre appliquer d'abord A puis
B, et appliquer d'abord B puis A. Ces crochets angulaires
ici signifient que tu prends ce qu'on appelle la valeur d'expectation de ce qui est à l'intérieur. En gros, si tu faisais la même
mesure un très grand nombre de fois, la valeur d'expectation est la valeur moyenne de toutes ces mesures. Aujourd'hui, nous allons
effectivement tester et vérifier ce principe d'incertitude sur un ordinateur quantique IBM. Nous examinerons trois
observables d'un qubit, montrerons que leurs opérateurs ne commutent pas, et enfin nous pourrons prouver que le
principe d'incertitude est vérifié pour ces observables de qubit. D'abord, un bref aparté sur un moyen utile de visualiser l'état
quantique d'un qubit. Il peut être représenté par un vecteur pointant vers un endroit sur une sphère appelée la sphère de Bloch. J'en ai parlé
dans une vidéo précédente dont le lien est dans la description, mais je vais te faire un rapide résumé ici aussi. Voici la
sphère de Bloch. Chaque vecteur est paramétré par deux angles, thêta et phi.
L'état zéro est au pôle nord et l'état un est au pôle sud, et une superposition égale de 0 et 1 se trouve
quelque part le long de l'équateur, où phi est égal à la phase relative entre les deux parties de la
superposition. Donc cet état ici serait égal
à 1 sur racine de 2 fois 0 plus e à la puissance i phi fois 1, où i est cette
phase. Quand nous mesurons une observable du qubit, le résultat est toujours l'une de deux options correspondant aux deux
états possibles du qubit. Pour l'expérience que nous allons faire, nous examinerons trois observables et
leurs opérateurs correspondants X, Y et Z. Quand tu mesures l'une de ces observables, tu obtiens soit plus un, soit
moins un, avec une probabilité pour chaque qui dépend de l'angle entre le vecteur du qubit sur la sphère de Bloch et
l'axe de mesure. Comme tu peux t'y attendre, Z mesure le long de l'axe Z, X le long de X,
et Y le long de Y. Rappelle-toi maintenant que nous parlons d'observables car avec un système
quantique, nous ne pouvons plus simplement connaître des choses sur le système sans les mesurer.
Et chaque observable a une opération correspondante, car les mesures nécessitent des opérations. Ce n'est peut-être pas évident, mais
il s'avère que les opérations, appelées opérateurs, qui correspondent à chacune de ces observables X, Y et Z sont
des rotations de pi autour de leurs axes respectifs. Donc X est une rotation autour de X, Y
autour de Y, et Z autour de Z. Alors, pour voir si ces opérateurs commutent ou non, nous pouvons vérifier si les rotations
sur une sphère commutent. Si oui, le principe d'incertitude ne s'appliquera pas et nous pourrions connaître X, Y et Z d'un qubit
avec une précision parfaite. S'ils ne commutent pas, alors nous pourrons trouver une nouvelle relation d'incertitude pour le qubit. Regarde
le point sur cette balle quand je fais d'abord une rotation autour de X, puis autour de Y. Il finit
ici. Maintenant essayons dans l'ordre inverse : je fais d'abord une rotation autour de Y, puis
autour de X. Il finit là-bas. Donc ils ne commutent définitivement pas. Cela signifie
que nous ne pouvons pas connaître simultanément les valeurs exactes X, Y et Z d'un qubit. Nous aurons une
relation d'incertitude. Nous passerons sur les détails ici, mais nous nous retrouvons avec trois relations d'incertitude
différentes. Nous avons : Delta X fois Delta Y
est supérieur ou égal à Z, Delta Y fois Delta Z est supérieur ou
égal à X, et Delta Z fois Delta X est supérieur ou égal
à Y. Donc le produit de deux quelconques de ces incertitudes est toujours supérieur ou
égal à la valeur d'expectation de la troisième observable. Utilisons Qiskit pour voir ce qui
se passe quand nous essayons de mesurer à la fois Z et X de l'état zéro. Mesurer Z est facile : c'est la base dite standard
de l'ordinateur quantique. Les mesures se font toujours selon Z par défaut. Mais pour mesurer X, nous devons effectuer ce qu'on appelle un
changement de base, en faisant essentiellement tourner la sphère de Bloch pour que X pointe maintenant vers le haut, là où Z pointait avant. Pour cela,
nous utilisons une gate Hadamard. Donc le circuit quantique complet ressemblera à ceci : nous mesurons en Z, appliquons le Hadamard,
puis mesurons en X. Si nous utilisons la primitive Qiskit sampler pour exécuter cette expérience plusieurs fois, nous
obtenons un histogramme des résultats de mesure qui ressemble à ceci pour la mesure
en Z, et à ceci pour la mesure en X. Comme tu peux le voir, nous avons mesuré le
qubit dans l'état zéro selon Z avec pratiquement 100 % de certitude, mais
selon X, nous ne savions pratiquement rien de l'état du qubit. Il a été mesuré soit zéro, soit un avec une probabilité
égale, ce qui signifie que notre incertitude en X était aussi grande que possible. Cela nous donne
un aperçu de ce compromis d'incertitudes, mais nous pouvons faire un peu mieux. Sur notre ordinateur quantique, nous pouvons utiliser une
primitive Qiskit appelée estimator pour trouver les valeurs d'expectation de nos observables X, Y et Z et
l'incertitude de chacune. Essayons pour l'état pointant dans la direction plus X sur la sphère de Bloch. Nous utiliserons estimator
pour calculer les incertitudes en X et Z pour cet état et la valeur d'expectation de
Y. Avec cet état, nous obtenons ce résultat de Qiskit. Quand nous prenons le produit des deux
incertitudes en X et Y, nous voyons que, comme attendu, il est plus grand que la valeur
absolue de la valeur d'expectation de Y. Mais c'était pour un seul état particulier. Nous voulons nous assurer que cette inégalité
est vraie pour tous les états de qubit. Utilisons donc estimator à nouveau, mais cette fois nous lui demanderons de balayer les valeurs d'un
paramètre et de trouver les valeurs d'expectation à chaque valeur de paramètre que nous lui donnons. Ici, le paramètre que nous voulons
balayer est l'angle thêta sur la sphère de Bloch, afin de vérifier l'inégalité pour tous les états de qubit qui se trouvent sur
cet arc qui intersecte le plan XZ. Quand nous faisons cela, nous obtenons un graphique en fonction de l'angle thêta. La courbe
rouge est le produit des deux incertitudes et la courbe orange est la valeur d'expectation de Y. Comme attendu,
le produit des incertitudes en X et Z est bien plus élevé que la valeur d'expectation de Y. Mais ce n'était pas
trop difficile de satisfaire l'inégalité car la valeur d'expectation de Y était si basse, elle était nulle pour tous les états sur
cet arc. Faisons un balayage similaire des valeurs de thêta, mais au lieu de balayer dans le plan XZ, fixons phi égal à pi sur
4, de sorte que nous regardions les états de qubit qui se trouvent sur un arc différent de la sphère. Ici, nous voyons que l'inégalité est
mise davantage à l'épreuve puisque la courbe orange et la courbe rouge sont plus proches, mais la rouge est toujours au-dessus de l'orange
et le principe d'incertitude tient toujours. Nous n'avons pas vérifié tous les états, mais tu commences certainement à saisir
l'idée : il y a une impossibilité fondamentale de connaître simultanément deux aspects complémentaires d'un système
quantique, y compris ce qubit que nous avons utilisé. Le principe d'incertitude nous force à admettre que peu importe
nos efforts, peu importe l'ingéniosité de nos mesures, nous ne pourrons jamais tout connaître avec une précision parfaite.
Il n'y a pas moyen de contourner cela. Vraiment. Si tu ne me crois pas, ou même si tu me crois, je te mets au défi : va consulter le module
dont le lien se trouve dans la description et essaie de battre le principe d'incertitude. Merci d'avoir regardé et à la prochaine fois.